Purdue Pharma you're familiar there's a
terrific movie Michael Keaton movie dope
sick that was oh yes okay uh and this is
if you need an opioid Purdue farmer will
sell you them at a reasonable price
whether you need them or not
I should add yeah these opioids can be
quite Moorish and even some would say
addictive so do be cautious
you were there right there was a time
where I did become a little bit
dependent on heroin thankfully perju
were not operating in my country so I
may not be here now and I'm very
grateful that I am
well and we are too
and there's something called hillbilly
heroine that's that's called Oxycontin
and that's what they were pushing but I
just in October 2020 when the justice
department announced Purdue farmer
pleaded guilty the felony charges of
defrauding federal agencies violating
anti-kickback laws marketing opioids to
hundreds of doctors that had suspected
were writing illegal prescriptions and
then lying about it to the DEA so they
got slapped with an 8.3 billion dollar
fine I'm just my last question is just
the cognitive dissonance that I see that
people see oh my God the pharmaceutical
industry is capable of doing this but
when it comes to covet no questions
asked
it just does seem weird Bill if I myself
I'll let him answer that oh they turn to
it well yeah you have a turn yeah
John I'll offer you this challenge get
the word sputum into your answer for
bonus points
I've been sitting here I've been sitting
here thinking about that the entire time
I could tell because I'm looking below
the desk
here we go you know I look we have a
complicated relationship with the
pharmaceutical industry anybody who's
ever had a uh a family member who's had
cancer uh and and seen what uh
life-saving drugs can do for people it
also may have given it to them it may
have but that's actually kind of my but
that's actually kind of my point is like
the reality is right like if you have a
black and white point of view the
pharmaceutical industry is engaging a
giant conspiracy to us all over you
are denying the reality that many people
have lives been saved by those drugs if
you say the pharmaceutical continuity
has no has is is incapable of error or
or malign Behavior you're equally an
idiot the reality is that in a
capitalist Society they're going to be
companies that seeking profit will do
things that are incredibly Innovative
and good and do things that are
incredibly terrible and and and and
exploitive that's just that seems like
the right position I agree let's just be
skeptical right okay and that's across
the board sure all right